hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the fragments
that we possess of the poem authored by
the pre-socratic philosopher Parmenides
of a lay up there is a choice that is
placed before him by the goddess who
he's talking with and it's an easy
choice for him he definitely knows which
side he's supposed to pick and he's also
advocating for us which side were
supposed to pick as well but it's a
choice between two fundamental ways of
looking at things or two roads paths
routes however you want to translate the
word Hodos which can mean any of those
and in a way it makes sense to talk
about it as a road or a path because you
know you're coming to a juncture point
where you have to make a decision and if
you go this way you're gonna see things
in one way if you go this way
well you're not only going to see things
in a different way you're also going to
wander around as he takes human beings
to be doing in all of their lifetimes if
they're not taking the the right road
and so the goddess makes a distinction
for him and also imposes a choice
there's a little bit of a paradox Akala
T to this that we'll explore
in just a bit actually there's a lot of
paradoxic ality to it but there's one
bit in particular that has to do with
bringing these two roads or roots before
the mind's eye and then requiring a
choice between them because it means
that he's not actually on either of them
at the moment that he is choosing so
there's there's a bit more to be
explained there so after the first part
where he goes to the you know the
different gates and justice opens them
up and all of that sort of stuff
the goddess says you are welcome it was
no ill fate that prompted you to travel
this way which is indeed far from mortal
men beyond their beaten paths so this is
already a new way of proceeding and he
says no no it was right and justice you
must learn everything and here's where
the distinction comes between the two
paths you must learn everything
both the steady heart of well-rounded
truth or persuasive truth the heart of
truth on a face hate or literally the
word for heart but it could be the core
and that is that word for truth Alafaya
right just placed into the genitive
indicating you know the origin or
something like that so that's one part
of it the other possibility is the
beliefs the Dokes i the opinions of
mortals both I those those who are not
immortal right and she goes on to say
that in these there is no true trust or
belief and the word belief there is
translating pissed ease which we also
translate as faith so not quite the same
thing as doke so something you might
consider to be deeper more
Stan's shove right but notice there's
that word la face there as well
so one path is the path of truth of
genuine truth the other is what appears
to be true to mortal beings but is not
actually true and in fact is lacking in
truth which means that it's it's false
so she goes on and says you shall learn
them too and come to see how beliefs
must exist in an acceptable form all
persuasive all-pervasive as they all
together are so she's saying you have to
actually make some sort of decision
between these and then in section 2 of
the poem going by deals you know
numbering we have two different routes
two different hodo roads sketched out
and here we run into some metaphysical
principles so it's no longer just about
truth it's about being and existence or
business if you want to say all right to
make a sort of neologism there so we
have a trustworthy route or path and
then we have one that's untrustworthy a
divine path a human path a path that's
in touch with truth a path that's in
error
so what defines these that it is now you
might say walk
that's a weird road sign isn't it you
telling me that it is this is the path
of being not just being being a knight
in Greek the word for to be what it is
to genuinely exist and so that it is is
one you could say name for this path in
Greek hopeful sistine and then also
along with this is a correlative
non-being cannot be holds Augustine
right host that or or you know that it
is the K
augustin it is not the case it is not it
does not exist mae ni mae is the greek
word for not it's a privat of in this
case right and I is the word for being
so non being or lack of being or not
being cannot be cannot exist so you
should let that sink in a little bit
that that is what defines this path the
realization that being is non being
cannot be so what about the other side
that it is not hos Lucas ting that what
is not that anything is not so mortals
say that that something isn't that there
is non being in some way within
existence and that for Parmenides is
sort of a sign of error sign that
there's something drastically wrong
there and then there's another Greek
phrase that's associated with it that
something must not be or you know
there's there's other ways of
translating it it cannot it must not be
there's there's different ways to say it
the Greek is host crayon s da ni that
non being that not to be may ni has to
be so this is the route of mortals they
they don't realize according to
Parmenides that it's impossible for non
being to be or are not being or whatever
is the opposite of being to be there is
strictly speaking no opposite of being
in this case he goes on a little bit
further and this and says this is the
path of trust for truth attends it and
then this is the path of untruth then a
little bit later he's going to talk
about
is how we actually access this so this
is in fragment seven for never shall
this be overcome so that things that are
not are you should restrain your
thinking your thought no way mo from
this way of seeking and then she says do
not let habit
Athos in Greek compel you along this
well-tried path
don't let habit of thinking the way that
human beings tend to think draw you away
from the trustworthy path into the
untrustworthy path
she also says don't allow your senses to
draw you in there and she mentions the
eye the ear and the tongue each of these
sees a plurality of sensations and
things changing Parmenides is actually
telling us on this path that there is no
change there is no motion everything is
one and that's what the truth is our
senses deceive us into thinking that
there's a multiplicity and that things
come into being or see cease to be right
generation and corruption so a little
bit later she's going to say on this way
there are many signs indicating that
what is is unborn and imperishable and
tire alone of its kind unshaken and
complete it was not once nor will it be
since it is now all together single and
continuous we mistakenly think because
we trust habit or we trust our eyes ears
and tongue or other senses that there is
a distinction within what is and that
there are many different things and that
they come into being and disappear and
can be destroyed a little bit further on
well actually still in fragment seven
she tells him that she that he should
use reason to come to a decision on this
contentious test that that she has
announced so this is the way of thinking
which seems to be counterintuitive right
it goes against our normal way of
understanding things
it goes against our culture but
Parmenides is advocating a monism saying
that everything that exists is genuinely
one and that thought and reason help us
to see this to be the case so what else
can we say about this
she is imposing this choice on him
saying you have to decide between these
you have to decide whether to trust your
reason and thought on the path that I've
spelled out for you or to be like
another human being and trust in all
this other stuff and be deluded she goes
on a little bit later and she says that
this path ought to be left on the
thought and you know literally just the
the privet --iv of think something that
is thought and nameless not given a name
because it's not a true way and again
that word truth on atheists is used this
is not really a true way it's not a path
anywhere it's simply a wandering around
this path however is as she says a true
path it's a real path and here is a
rather unusual Greek term at 8 - moon
which signifies that this this is
reality itself and so Parmenides is
being given a choice coming down you
know ostensibly in this poem from a
goddess offering a genuine insight into
reality as opposed to a wrongheaded view
that's not even into reality but into
illusion now there is as I mentioned a
bit of a paradox here the fact that
there is a choice between these and that
reason makes that choice doesn't that
seem to imply that somehow this
non-being is involved in being and he's
not the same thing as the goddess is he
since he went on a trip with this
goddess and then she's revealing things
to him well you could say that that's
actually you know
the framework or the cover of this path
that Parmenides is using to get this
point across to the reader and that if
Parmenides is actually correct there is
no goddess there is no you and me we're
all just this thought thinking itself
this thought that is identical to being
that's a little bit tough to wrap your
head around but that is one of the
implications if we follow out this logic
of the two paths
you